c'est un anniversaire qui est passé
inaperçu à cause de la crise du
coronavirus le 3 octobre 1995
bernadette chirac inaugurait la maison
des parents au sein de l'hôtel
clocheville à tours une structure
indépendante qui a pour but d'accueillir
les proches de personnes hospitalisées
vingt-cinq ans après la structure est
toujours là et bien chaque jour une
trentaine de personnes en pension
complète
le point sur cet établissement
associatif avec hélène chapelet
à la maison des parents les proches des
personnes hospitalisées peuvent souffler
un peu c'est le cas de sandra 46 ans
depuis le mois de septembre cette maman
a arrêté de travailler pour se consacrer
à son fils de 11 ans malade d'une
leucémie
sandra vite à romorantin mais pour être
au plus près de son enfant elle a décidé
de poser ses bagages dans cette
structure ouverte 365 jours par an est
située juste à côté de l'hôpital
clocheville à tours qu'on nous appelle à
l'hôpital on est là on n'a pas besoin de
faire des kilomètres
si on nous téléphone pour nous dire ça
va pas fort venir tout de suite on n'a
pas une heure de route et les bénévoles
ils sont toujours là on leur dit des
fois qu'on n'est pas bien donc il nous
rassure un peu
depuis son inauguration le 3 octobre
1995 par bernadette chirac
l'établissement a accueilli entre 80 et
100 mille proches de personnes
hospitalisées
des papas et des mamans qui veulent être
aux côtés de leurs enfants à clocheville
mais également des proches d'adultes
accueillis dans les hôpitaux publics ou
privés de la métropole ici neuf salariés
et une trentaine de bénévoles font
fonctionner l'établissement et veille à
maintenir un lien avec les résidents
chez nous vous sonnez en vous ou on vous
accueille
on vous fait à soi et on écoute parce
que très souvent les résidents arrivent
très angoissée en grande souffrance un
beaucoup d'urgences de personnes en
réanimation
donc on écoute si la personne a besoin
on ne parle pas d'autre chose et ensuite
on leur explique la marche de la maison
30 chambres sont disponibles toute
l'année
leur prix est fixé en fonction des
revenus du foyer pour une nuit et trois
repas pris sur place le montant varie de
15 à 40 2 euros un prix bien en dessous
des tarifs hôteliers pour ne pas mettre
en difficulté financière des personnes
qui vivent déjà un moment éprouvant